e andare incontro al futuro con la
determinazione non soltanto di credere
alle nuove idee
quando di fuggire
grazie a tutti per essere qua io sono
una critica d'arte una curatrice ma oggi
vi parlerò di un progetto che si chiama
food e concentra tutta la sua attenzione
la passione e la creatività nel rapporto
tra arte e cibo
ma prima di cominciare a raccontarvi
cos'è questa idea io vorrei fare un
gioco con voi e quindi vi chiedo che
relazione vedete tra questa immagine e
quest altra immagine
sono consapevole che le fate scorrere in
modo veloce quindi ve le pongo una di
fianco all'altra
così le potete vedere per bene siamo in
due contesti completamente diversi da
una parte una gara sportiva da un'altra
parte
il buffet c'è un elemento sulla carta e
non si vede che però le leve in modo
imprescindibile perché lui immagini si
tratta di questa linea questa linea
rossa che una sorta di frontiera uno
stop ma la cosa più importante di questa
linea e che ci permette di immaginare di
capire quale sarà il frame successivo di
entrambe le situazioni cioè ci sarà uno
slancio uno slancio vitale in entrambi i
casi
adesso mi interessa capire quali sono le
qualità per questo slancio cioè cosa
serve per essere vincenti per essere
vittoriosi per portare a casa
l'obiettivo
ve lo mostro con un'altra immagine che
le trovo molto esemplificativa per le
qualità emerge determinazione la
capacità di sfidare i propri limiti e
importantissima coraggio una certa dose
di tenacia e fondamentale per affrontare
determinate situazioni molto
consapevolezza del sé costanza e
coordinazione sono anche pronto un
obiezione ovvero vi sto mostrando
un'immagine sportiva quindi immagino che
voi pensiate beh è prossima alla prima
immagine quella della corsa non a quella
del buffet in realtà non è così
queste sono le qualità essenziali per
chi si approccia ad un buffet da qui da
qui volete dirmi che non emerge
consapevolezza del sé cioè sapere cosa
andare a prendere un buffet è
fondamentale sono situazioni in cui si
sfidano sempre i propri limiti fisici
altra immagine emerge costanza e tenacia
sono sicura che tutti voi avete fatto un
quarto d'ora di schiele per prendere un
bicchiere di vino e un pezzo di pane in
dubbio infine immagine che un po le
caratteristiche le riassume tutte quante
le tre grazie
da qui emerge determinazione molta
determinazione e coordinazione e sia
coordinazione individuale perché bisogna
passare con la forchetta nelle braccia
altrui prendere la fetta di mortadella
riporla sul piatto senza farla cadere e
coordinazione anche con il compagno con
cui per esempio siamo andati all'evento
perché immagino che una situazione di
questo tipo l'avete vissuta io vado a
prendere il vino per prendere i formaggi
trovare prendere qualcos'altro poi ci
troviamo lì è così investiamo bene il
nostro tempo
allora bene tutto questo mi serve per
farvi capire che ci sono queste qualità
che servono sono essenziali perché
tornando alle immagini in italy ci
stiamo approcciando quello che è un vero
e proprio assalto nel primo caso
l'assalto è al traguardo
nel secondo caso l'assalto è al buffet
ma c'è una differenza fondamentale tra
queste due immagini
nel primo caso motivazione e obiettivo
coincidono
quindi il corridore sa dal primo momento
in cui si è legato alle scarpe che veli
e glieli il suo motivo è il traguardo il
podio nel secondo caso invece c'è uno
scollamento individuale
fortissimo tra motivazione e obiettivo
le persone che sono lì non sono lì per
non stanno pensando al matrimonio nella
mostra ne a qualsiasi altro evento per
cui sono stati invitati stanno solo
pensando a mangiare ed è in questo
frangente di ricerca che si inserisce il
progetto l'idea creativa food ed allora
tutto questo che vi ho raccontato in
modo ironico è perché sono consapevole
che quando si parla di cibo
c'è qualcosa proprio più forte di noi è
un istinto non si può fermarsi è legato
alla memoria alla memoria età atavica
molto probabilmente e allora dico io ma
perché non trasformare questo agonismo
culinario in qualcosa di più con un
presupposto culturale e vi faccio un
esempio io sono critica d'arte con
l'attrice per cui le vedo spesso queste
situazioni inaugurazione di una mostra
vernissage
da una parte c'è la mostra dall'altra
parte c'è il buffet due momenti
completamente su coordinate sia dal
punto di vista contestuale che dal punto
di vista concettuale
addirittura ci sono le persone che vanno
alla mostra per postare direttamente al
buffet allora dicono ha visto che il
cibo è un linguaggio universale compreso
da tutti l'istintivo per cui e tutti
sono attratti perché non far sì che
questo momento del buffet posso
raccontare qualcosa di più sulla mostra
in fondo l'idea il progetto ha
l'ambizione solo di regalare un punto di
vista in più al fruitore del dell'evento
dice robert piercing mi piace molto
questa frase dallo zen e l'arte della
manutenzione della motocicletta
prendiamo una manciata di sabbia dal
mondo delle percezioni e le chiamiamo
mondo beh allora con food happy voglio
regalare a tutti quelli che
parteciperanno a un evento qualche
granello di sabbia in più perché
d'altronde abbiamo cinque sensi
ma quanti ne usiamo effettivamente per
percepire per giudicare spesso ci
fermiamo solo ed esclusivamente a quello
che vediamo bene abbiamo altri 4 e il
gusto per fu depp
fondamentale il convivio no perché
questi momenti sono momenti conviviali
il servizo la parola convivio dante già
nel 1300 all'inizio imposto quest'opera
che era una dissertazione filosofica
culturale di 15 trattati impostando i
temi come fossero una mensa beh cosa
significa anziché cosa valore
all'interno del discorso che vi sta
facendo che il cibo è cultura e lo è la
sua fruizione
non a caso un'altra metafora
quotidianamente diciamo nutrire le
proprie menti o nutrire le menti beh
come fa allora fu detto a nutrire le
menti utilizza un valore che è il valore
estetico estetica e dove la parola
estetica e proprio presa nell'accezione
etimologica dal greco ai estesi
percepire con i sensi che poi la parola
sia di ambito comune nelle arti visive
anti è la filosofia dell'arte ben venga
infatti food è proprio battiato dal
sistema dell'arte suo il suo motore per
per creare per dare
nutrizione alle menti e ci affidiamo
quando però il trovare plurale perché
siamo in tre ci affidiamo a una
disciplina artistica che è l'happening
spiego due minuti
che cos'è l'happening perché allora
avete capito come funziona fu depp è una
disciplina recente l'happening della
metà degli anni cinquanta che concentra
tutta la sua attenzione non solo oggetto
fisico in sé quindi non su pittura
scultura fotografia ma sull'evento che
sta per capitare
e si badi bene non sull'evento come
potrebbe essere una rappresentazione
teatrale in cui vado mi siedo osservo no
sulle su un evento che esiste perché gli
eau fruitore di partecipo cioè come se
l'artista un artista di di di happening
avesse creato una bomba con una miccia
però la miccia la deve accendere allo
spettatore altrimenti l'evento non
esplode non funziona e da qui potete
capire anche cosa significhi le
motivazioni del nome food che non ha
bisogno di spiegazioni ed è più che la
troncatura di happening poi la polisemia
meravigliosa per cui e poi diventare
epiche è il nostro nostro modo infatti
vi ho fatto iniziare con un gioco è come
aperitivo l'espressione il massimo della
convivialità contemporanea
apcom e appetito che in origine appetito
significa proprio aspirare a e quindi
raccoglie le finalità dell'arte del cibo
e di fu depp
tra i tanti eventi che abbiamo fatto
bene voglio raccontare uno che ha avuto
discreto successo e che forse è il più
il più esemplificativo vi parlo del
sapore dei colori pensato e realizzato
per l'inaugurazione della mostra di
matisse a brescia allora vi faccio
vedere proprio come funziona a tavolino
mi chiedo con i miei colleghi la domanda
è ok
che cosa è matisse per il pubblico cioè
non per me che sono critica d'arte per
cui vado a vedere anche il dettaglio e
pelo sul luogo di matisse
ma per la larga massa che andrà a un
buffet per la larga massa che frequenta
il buffet e soprattutto meglio dire che
cosa è matisse
beh mathis è colore nell'immaginario
collettivo ok allora come possiamo
tradurre il colore in aspetto culinario
il risultato è stato questo il risultato
sono stati dei tubetti di sapore dove il
rosso era la crema diga spaccio e via
discorrendo con la mousse di mortadella
l'aceto balsamico la crema di parmigiano
e il crema di zucca il tutto concepito
in un allestimento che riprendeva
contestuale quindi abbiamo trasformato
la sala in una sorta di tavolozza dove
ad ogni colore corrispondeva un sapore
da una situazione iniziale quindi di
questo tipo siamo arrivati ad avere
delle vere e proprie tavole cromatiche
ok mi diletto e come funziona e funziona
così vuoi mangiare pane mortadella
prendi la tua fetta di pane prende il
tubetto rosa book il tubetto estremi il
tubetto vi assicuro che all'inizio tutto
questo ha creato un forte in pas un po
perché siamo in un museo per cui non si
sa mai quello che si può toccare non si
può toccare il discrimine è un po perché
è una situazione fuori dal normale cioè
non assolutamente non è
usuale fare avere un approccio del
genere in un aperitivo soprattutto in un
aperitivo istituzionale come era una
mostra come era la mostra di questo tipo
funziona va esattamente in questo modo
questa immagine fra l'altro è
esemplificativa del concetto di
innovazione cioè dove sta l'innovazione
in food ep parto allora dalla
definizione che ne diede shin bet work è
il primo teorizzatore dell'innovazione
disse l'innovazione è la combinazione di
elementi preesistenti
e chiaro che io non ho inventato nel
afragola nell'aceto balsamico o però
proposto questa combinazione innovativa
a scorrere adesso vi faccio vedere
l'immagine io ho visto il lecito
guardate non guardate i tubetti che
tanto li avete visti guardate le
espressioni per altri il volto guardate
le emozioni che emergono dalle dalle
immagini questa signora qua si vede
dall'abbigliamento non ha mai spremuto
un tubetto di colore in vita sua
meno che meno di sapore vi assicuro ma
ve lo assicuro che quel giorno si è
sbizzarrita altra immagine qui non posso
fare a meno che cita aristotele nella
metafisica dice lo stupore è la prima
forma della conoscenza
beh allora a questo punto penso che
l'obiettivo di fu depp sia stato
pienamente raggiunto ancora vado
veramente vi sollecito guardare
l'espressività
questo momento conviviale un vero
momento conviviale con vivere vivere
assieme una situazione questo è
l'happening in questo momento sta
provvedendo che cosa mette in moto un
happening rispetto alla situazione in
dvd
pensa a prendere il proprio piattina
mangiarselo per sé
gli happening sono imprevedibili
ovvero io in scena un meccanismo che
però non sapendo non posso sapere le
reazioni del pubblico e quindi non so
mai come va a finire un evento e non
avevo di certo pensato che un tubetto
potesse fare una fine del genere somma
essere apprezzato talmente tanto il
volto mi dà parecchia soddisfazione
questa immagine di soddisfazione me
nella doppia
anzitutto perché siamo di fronte a
giancarlo galan
all'epoca ministro della cultura insomma
che vi faccio vedere un'immagine dopo la
proprio assaporato con piacere e poi
perché mi sembra di ricordare che è
sempre le francesi di quella parrocchia
qualcuno avesse detto che con la cultura
non si mangia e quindi insomma a
confutare visto che ce n'è bisogno di
persone per cambiare le cose cominciamo
con un'immagine di questo tipo per
confutare quello che queste dicerie vane
fra l'altro vi vorrei salutare infine
con un'immagine con scusata con una
citazione che riassume proprio quella
che è l'anima il cuore e le intenzioni
di fu depp
se la fame la sete sono gli impulsi
primitivi dell'uomo nella bestia
l'associare tali impulsi a valori
estetici e servire la causa della
cultura ben più efficacemente che le
noiose e oziose dissertazioni immorali e
filosofiche e perché no
gabriele d'annunzio